super excited for this talk kimone
dracopoulos is with us today Timon is a
assistant professor at the business
school at USC Marshall
he works on economics of networks
information economics a bunch of
different things but for a purpose of
today one thing he did do was he was uh
was a data science and analytics
operations advisor okay I added an extra
word somewhere there data science and
operations advisor to the Greek
government in 2020 and so he's going to
tell us about work he did there to do
efficient and targeted covid-19 testing
thank you very much Irene you can hear
me I'm presuming cool yeah so today I'm
going to talk about some work that we
did with the Greek governments together
with people who are much better than I
am hamsa who's sitting there and uh and
Vishal Gupta from USC our chief
engineering architect John lagoyanis and
all these names at the bottom are the
epidemiologists from the Greek side that
works very closely with us for this
project
so today it's an interesting day uh
November 10th was the day that we shut
down the system uh two years ago so it's
a it's an important and important date
so backtracking a few years back I
started working on academics related
problems during my during my PhD 2012
and that was my hope thesis so it was
2016. I just got a job and like people
hide it directly or indirectly were
telling me like why the hell are you
working on epidemics it's 2016. it's
never gonna happen again famous last
words right and so yeah then when I was
visiting Ali actually at Duke early
early 2020 was the first science of
community transition of this unknown
virus covid-19 and the moment you share
communal transmission if you have worked
for like two days on epidemics you know
that things are not gonna go well so
after ordering half of Amazon I started
thinking about like how we can how we
can be helpful
so the first thing that I worked on in
covid-19 for covid-19 that I am not
going to discuss in detail today I was
hearing about the FBA not accepting if
the who test for covet because of
accuracy concerns
and so we wrote this very simple models
a model about testing where we show that
where you have abundance of tests then
sure you want the test to be super
accurate but then what we show is that
when you have scarcity which was the
case for 2020 actually the opposite
happens it may be optimal for a social
welfare maximizer to not even realize
the full potential of the tests or in
other words don't care too much about
accuracy care about scaling them okay
so this paper like we started it in
February we were done
in February
and I started thinking like okay enough
with insights like there is a crisis
going on maybe it's a good time to do
something more like try to to change
something in an efficient world and then
that's when the project that I will be
talking about today started so
essentially the question is okay we have
been developing all these amazing tools
and you guys are much better than me are
developing very sophisticated tools for
using data operationalizing data how can
we be relevant in this crisis
and our way of thinking can it be can it
provide interesting and effective
insights for public health for
epidemiology so we can change policy
so the quick answer of today's like The
quick summary of today's talk is a yes
we can be very relevant even with simple
things and B yes we can provide novel
novel insights actually we're gonna show
at the end of the talk using data that
the policy decisions at the time were
not that great
foreign
we actually implemented this work at the
Greek Border in 2020 we worked with 300
doctors and nurses 200 policemen and
firemen 32 Laboratories process the data
anonymized of millions of visitors and
we were directly reporting to
the Greek Prime Minister the deputy
minister of civil protection and the
Secretary General of Public Health
the reason I'm mentioning this is that
the organizers asked me and I think it's
actually an interesting component of the
project to talk a little bit about how
this collaboration works when you're
working on technical stuff
so I'll be talking a little bit about
that and I have a slide at the end
that's I I made for this talk that kind
of summarizes the lessons that I learned
the hard way
all right at any point obviously you you
stop and interrupt me
okay so let's say let's take the problem
first it's early 2020 and Greece was one
of the first countries to go on lockdown
they were extremely conservative until
May
all right so then Kobe I don't know if
you remember the time started ramping
down a little bit
and what was the situation that the
degree camera Greek government was
facing the Greeks in the room know that
we don't have an I.T sector and we have
a very small manufacturing sector so
service industry is crucial and tourism
is like a huge percentage of that
so the question is okay do we open up
the borders or not
okay
now
I lied the question was not Dewey is how
do we do it so the European Union at the
time gave this advice
that all member states Who start
considering removing the the limits on
non-essential travel starting July 1st
and what was their advice at the time
just keep an eye on the epidemiological
situation as is reported by different
countries and member states and based on
these metrics you feel free to adapt
your travel protocols but July 1st at
least within you you should alive allow
free travel yeah
all right so what I'm going to show
today is that we as a community can help
in doing this effectively open up the
Border but this advice at the time was
terribly wrong
okay
wait sorry can you go back yeah
so I sometimes they were saying look at
the evidence number of cases over 14
days normalized multiplication for
compared countries if something looks
bad do something about it okay if it's
as big as a and that's ineffective
because it's right I'll show you exactly
how it's actually way more than that
I'm going to show that
even if you if you have a double policy
that's the same across countries it has
no informational value I'll make it I'll
make the statement very precise a little
bit but yeah
wait
okay so just to remind you what the
situation was in 2020
there were no vaccines
only PCR tests were approved so there
were no rapid tests that were approved
and what's the problem with PCR tests as
you know
they require specialized equipment the
whole world was demanding this equipment
they could not produce them fast enough
hence
the number of tests you could perform in
a day was very very limited so for
Greece the whole country could do
something like 15 000 tests per day
that's a very very small number compared
to the millions that we're hearing today
yeah
and this is not something that you can
scale so it's not a matter of cost it's
not that they were cheap and they didn't
want to do more tests it's that's what
they could not
right there was not enough technical
capacity for it okay
also we didn't know much about covid-19
right it was a time where we thought
that women are less prone to covid-19
that men it was a time where literally
they were teaching us how to wash our
hands and that was like our protection
against coverage we didn't know if
people could be asymptomatic and
contagious we didn't know anything about
it okay
okay so what could they do what were
they planning to do so they had a
limited number of tests let's say they
were planning to do half of the tests of
the fifteen thousands or roughly 7 500
at the border clearly they were
expecting more than 7 500 tourists per
day so you could only around like sample
or test a subset of the population and
their plan was literally to have a
clicker one every 10 tours you test them
the other nine are up okay
okay then your second level as a country
is what we call Gray listing
what is grade listing I choose a subset
of the countries and whoever is visiting
from that country I require a negative
PCR test
here what's the problem with this policy
that there were not enough PCR tests in
other countries too and like our
analysis shows that the moment you
impose a PCR a negative PCR constraint
the arrivals from that country dropped
by 50 percent ish
so you see that this is a very
non-trivial decision you don't want to
go wild with realistic countries
otherwise like if you're trying to run a
tourist-based economy with 50 less
arrivals during covet then you're better
off just calling the day
the third theoretical option was red
listing to say that whoever comes from
country X I'm going to quarantine to to
put them in quarantine for two weeks
again a impractical you cannot host on
these people
maybe you cannot do it there are privacy
concerns like it's just not
implementable so those were those were
the two levels
so far so good
all right what we ended up doing was
something a lot more complicated all
right so here's how the system that we
designed and implemented works
every household
at least 24 hours prior to arrival they
submit the plf form passenger locator
form
that essentially has information about
okay where did you spend the last two
weeks how old are you
where are you planning to go in Greece
with city which region are you from
where are you heading to in Greece and
other more operational information okay
now every day the anonymized Manifest of
passengers together with the features is
provided to us Eva is a nickname for our
system for reasons that we don't even
know so
Eva
so we get this anonymized list manifest
of passengers
together with the features and we are
asked to select
with subsets of them do we do we
recommend the Border agency test which
subset do we allow to leave the airport
or the board of Entry without a test
subject to the budget constraints for
every Port of Entry how many tests I can
perform at every Port of Entry cool
all right those who are recommended to
be tested are going to be met by a
doctor at the border the border the the
Border agent or the doctor takes a
sample and they send it to the labs
the labs analyze and give the result in
24 to 48 hours that's an important
detail
okay yeah
um were they quarantined during that 24
to 48 hours yes that's so essential it's
not quarantined so they were said give
me the precise location of where you're
going to be stay in your hotel room if
we don't find you there there's going to
be a humongous fine and out of the
people that we found positive a very
small percentage were not able to be
located immediately and we're not out of
the other location
yeah
if anyone travel to Greece in 2020 by
the way
I did yeah all right so there is a point
that I'm trying to make later okay good
yeah
I can I can use the microphone
for the PLS form were you testing
somehow whether they were uh correctly
accurately like reporting and especially
for the future information of where
they're going to be I mean you can put
everything I mean for past information
presumably yeah fantastic question
thanks so let me break it up into two
components a there is no check that you
can do practically but
the interesting thing is that our our
approach is agnostic to what the name of
the country that you're coming from is
it's just building a type so you had all
these smarter scripts who were traveling
from country X and in order to confuse
the system they would put us origin
Greece and then the algorithm just
learns Athens Greece as a type and they
get tested heavily because they were
ending up testing positive so you know
obviously there are ways to game the
system but not many
now what was your second question remind
me
it's for similarly for future
information about where they're going to
be because yeah so the constraint is
that like civil protection I would go
and find them and put them in quarantine
if they are positive and that's what my
answer to Rachel was before the huge
majority of people where were they said
so what is important for us is the Port
of Entry if you declare that you are
going to Athens and you are entering
through Athens and you show up at a land
border they won't let you in the country
for 24 hours
because you are violent like we have a
budget for that point of entry so it's a
travel Document so either won't let you
in
all right so the results will go back in
the system in 24 to 48 hours there look
to the Greek government Central database
and we get aggregated anonymized
pseudonymized uh results that we use to
improve our estimates and therefore
improve our improve our allocation hence
that's closing the loop is a
reinforcement learning component
who are you
now going back to how do you implement
these things I want to point out that
what we did is way more than a
reinforcement learning algorithm to make
this happen let's look at what
components you have to take into account
first there is a supply chain problem
there
you have like 30 30ish points of entry
and then you have equal number of labs
some of them are close to the lab some
are not so you have to take care of the
logistics and the compatibility of
samples with the equipment at every lab
and it's important to do this fast why
because you want the results to come
back fast so there is a supply chain
design issue to be answered there also
you need to work with the front-end
engineers and decide what does this form
what information does this form collect
subject to not violating gdpr HIPAA
privacy conference
yeah
all right and also there is the politics
of this so using a targeting algorithm
for Relevant decisions is very
complicated so essentially us and the
representatives of Greece at the EU we
have to work for like a couple of weeks
so that they can add this freaking
phrase at the beginning of like the
recommendation for travel that allows AI
tools to be useful screening at the
border
before they did that we couldn't
implement we couldn't deploy
yeah
all right so what does like these like
more boring problems what do they look
like as I said you have all this part of
Entry you have specific labs
and essentially
what you have to respect is every lab's
daily processing capacity geographical
being close enough so that you can send
the test fast and compatibility now all
of us are thinking all right come on
this is as Alex called it in his talk
Advanced machine learning it's like it's
an IEP right but the way that they did
it before is
huge Excel files where they were moving
tests around to find a feasible solution
and feasibility was a success metric
right
so my point is that sure for us it's
like in the homework problem but it's
not as trivial conceptually or
implementation for people with notes our
background and our skill set
okay
so going with the operations of this
then you would have to go to the border
and train the Border agents how to scan
QR codes how to log the results because
there is this problem of matching the
testing kit the sample with the person
and what's the solution that you would
think okay scan a barcode scan the QR
code of the passenger done but for us
it's like again two minutes we all got
it not the case General all right
and then
we would have to manage the front end
and the back end Engineers so that
privacy concerns are satisfied the front
end does not crash and collects all the
information that we want
and then oops
never underestimate as an advice for
this product the value of a dashboard
the dashboard is what gets you projects
right and also it buys it it builds the
trust between the US that we understand
the data science and executive decision
methods and then you have to go and
communicate with the decision makers the
good looking person in the picture is
the Greek Prime Minister which we had to
meet every other day so that a they can
sanity check what we're doing and B we
can tell them look the hot spots around
the world are this this and that now do
whatever you want you decide who the
greatest and who to not and they were in
general like accepting our
recommendations but you have to show it
with data because gray listing is a very
expensive decision politically and
economically
yeah at that point did they ever sorry
oh yeah I'm forgiving
I have a question which I feel like you
may be getting to like what is the
objective of the Greek government here I
owe you two answers I I promise I
remember
so operations vanilla traditional
optimization 101 is not as trivial as we
think and in order to implement this
landscape program problems you have to
think about the work together with more
fancy tools
okay
all right so getting to the objective
what are we trying to do we want to
recommend who to test out the border and
also have confident estimates for types
of passengers that look to be
problematic by type think about it as
country for now and I will make it more
specific and explain how we decide on
the features okay
so this screams exploration exploitation
which was the first big mistake that we
did in this project calling it
exploration exploitation
but I mean what is the trade-off here
you have good estimates about something
that looks risky you have bad estimates
High con Labs confidence intervals for
something that looks like less risky so
do you choose this one so if you improve
your estimates because maybe these
actually risk here or do you go for this
one and our community has looked at
a large number of possible solutions
uh UCB Thompson sampling getting syndex
and here comes the part where you're
working with like decision makers who
are not technical so you go to the first
meeting and you say UCB is very popular
trust us between these I'm going to
choose this point
and they're like but this is riskier
right
and then you go look next day you go and
say on the other hand there is a an
index that is quantifies risk both in
terms of uncertainty and actual risk at
the border so right performance wise we
agree in the team and based on like
experiments that we have done that they
are very comparable but again an index
type of policy givensive policy sounds
more transparent right and easier to
explain
and also it's very convenient for us
because as you will see we have some
pretty nice clothes from Solutions which
is helpful for computational purposes
Hui
yeah I'm a little surprised that you had
to reveal such finer details to the
executives so the way that it's so there
are two the formal and the informal
story so the way the process happened is
that we pitched a project to the Prime
Minister things like it sounds
reasonable but we have a good due
diligence with my scientific committee
and so there was a discussion with
epidemiologists essentially and the idea
of exploration was like right beyond the
imagination like why would you ever
explore
uh and then okay so we tried to convince
them and we were at this limbo state of
convincing and then we had the
presentation to the prime minister in
his cabinet and now where is like luck
is part of this the prime minister is a
person who dips his MBA at Stanford and
two corporations and stats and in my
opinion was like probably the smartest
person in the room including myself and
he was able to understand
very very well even if he could not like
write formulas obviously he was
understanding the intuition of this
Concepts very very well
and that's where the luck comes in that
it was a like stars aligned that we had
a very analytical minded top decision
maker
yeah but we had to go to that level of
detail
I was wondering how much exploration
actually uh gives you additional
information Beyond sort of like publicly
released information about covid rates
in different countries yeah that's
fantastic I we I will answer your
question together with Kevin's the
answer is public information does not
seem to add anything unfortunately and I
will try to show why
all right okay so now let's get to
formalizing what we're trying to do
if we have types think about countries
for now but in reality times times times
region times City Times age times gender
and every time you do it best
is a Bernoulli trial from
a distribution with unknown prevalence
right for its type you don't know what
percentage is infected or not that's the
whole point
and the problem is that these through
positivity through prevalence for every
type K is a unknown and B very
non-stationary
all right
and what's your decision how many arms
how many tests to allocate to type K how
many type K arms to pull
and what's your objective Cuts as many
infected people as possible
answer question one awesome all right
huge lie my decision is actually
[Music]
decide how many arms of 30k to pull in
point of entry e
right why because every point of entry
has their own budget
and also the mix of arrivals in
different points of Entry is very
heterogeneous for example do we have
anyone German here
okay so for example people from northern
Macedonia they only show up in a couple
of land borders because they are
geographical neighbors no one would fly
to Greece on the other hand Germans show
up everywhere
so there is a non-trivial decision to
make like it's a very combinatorial type
problem
so you have to satisfy the budget
constraints and the demand constraints
we
okay
so this problem ended up being
complicated and deviating from classical
results for a number of reasons that I
will sketch here
so first of all
the data was very imbalanced
surprisingly the order of positivity was
like one in a thousand two in a thousand
three hundred thousand so very few
positive tests because this was
asymptomatic population
I will explain how we dealt with this
and the second estimation challenge was
the high dimensionality of the feature
space so it's concrete times regions
times City Times age bracket times
gender so potentially huge number of
features
so let me give you a taste of how we
dealt with
have to use it at least once the
microphone
for the pfr was this accurate
information about uh who is going to
come or did you have many people uh
feeling the fpfr and then not showing up
yeah did you have like deterministic
essentially arrivals uh information
about arrival so it was there
uncertainty on that front fantastic let
me make sure that I understand the
question so the question is do you have
no shows right people filling up a plf
form are never showing up absolutely but
it's something that you usually can
account for so you inflate the budget by
the no shows of the past two weeks and
you're good pretty much good
yeah
plus minus 10 plus at the Port of Entry
there's a obviously make any difference
so yeah
yeah
I hear you are I use it yes
yeah okay so this is like a little bit
out there but um
did the to the ports of Entry ever like
ever like hit their budget for the day
before the day was over and if so what
did they do did they just like let these
people through that we're supposed to be
tested or do they figure out some mixed
meals
that's the question so
this is where being an engineer helps a
lot that's remember I said that the
constraint is that you have to submit
your form 24 hours in advance otherwise
you cannot enter the country
that's where this helps right you know
deterministically that at most that many
people will come you're inflated by the
no-show but and then like naturally
they're gonna be split during the day
now if I was doing this all over again
the thing that I would change that would
like try to split it between flights so
that people do not there's no peak
arrivals for the medical personnel but
obviously this was designed to implement
it in three months I wish I had done
this because and I would claim another
how important operations is but we
didn't
so you might have mentioned it but why
did every port of Wendy have their own
budget like it seems just adding
constraints to a problem that's already
hard yeah that's it that's a that's a
very good question so
I'll give you the Practical answer and
then the theoretical answer
um the Practical answer is the tests
also come with medical units that you
need to locate to Ports of Entry provide
food and provide a place to stay so it's
not the easy to move capacity around
because people are involved the
theoretical answer which we analyzed in
the second paper is that intuitively
let's forget about inflexibility of
moving resources around intuitively it
feels like an LP that like it should
have a bank bug solution find the
average positivity in Athens versus
salerniki and then if Athens on average
is worse put all your resources to
Athens right but here is the cuts that
because we're doing targeting the
objective is not linear anymore it's
concave so the optimal solution is
actually an integer Point solution
because you are cutting the tail of the
distribution because you're targeting
which is like a Hui
all right so how do we deal with
imbalanced data we essentially did cross
learning so you have a naturally defined
number of groups of country sort of
types the green listed the gray listed
that I explained and blacklisted that
were defined at the EU level these are
the No No countries you are not allowed
to come unless you're a citizen
so for every subgroup of countries
that's where the cross learning comes in
you fit a common prior of the
prevalences using the data
once you have a prior you did your close
learning and then to update your
posterior on every country you're just
performing basically
and that exposed analysis so that was a
very good idea being naive about
estimates would have been worse than
just guessing zero for every country
all right and then how did we deal with
the granularity the number of features
this is where we used ideas from hamsa's
work where essentially instead of
defining all possible features which
would have made it very hard to allocate
enough tests to every feature we just
identify the subtypes for every country
that are statistically riskier than the
rest of the country for example if this
is Spain and I will be using names of
countries randomly if this is Spain you
have different regions in Spain
you can identify running like a lasso
type regression that Barcelona seems
riskier so why don't we just split Spain
in two types
Spain Barcelona Andres Spain instead of
spending our resources in defining all
these unnecessary features make sense
so essentially we Define subtypes only
when we need them
all right and at the end of the day this
is where the dashboards come in for
every type that you have identified you
have an estimate of the risk
cool
all right and now we go to a location
where it's things are getting a little
more complicated
first of all the non-sationality is an
issue compared to classical results our
community has worked on this problem two
types of approaches exponential
smoothing or discarding all data which
is which was the first for Simplicity
and then the really challenging part of
this project was the fact that in
classic Bandits you pull one arm you see
what happens you update your estimates
life is great but here do you have any
information between pools
so I have 7 000 tests to allocates
I go for the first one Spain looks risky
or has a high index I'm allocating this
test to Spain and I have another 699
test to allocate did I learn anything in
between
no it will take two two days to get the
result
right
so there is it's Advanced it's a badge
problem
with delayed feedback and I will spend a
little bit of time to explain how we did
that and then there are these
combinatorial constraints that I talked
about that different countries different
parts of country have different budgets
and different arrivals
all right so
first of all the concept that we used
for uh for the index it's a what Vivek
and his father proposed it's a it's
essentially the
Givens index but assuming that you only
look one step ahead you don't look at
the whole Horizon and what's the big
advantage of this
hey it captures the fact that things are
very non-stationary so looking too far
to the Future doesn't really make sense
and very conveniently has a very
simple fixed Point equation to solve
so computational is very easy and why is
this important and here is the part that
Vishal hates me when I mention why is
computational efficiency important so
remember Rachel's comment it's midnight
and I have to decide the test for the
day
the first flight is arriving at 1205. so
this person needs a travel Document so
in five minutes
you have to run this thing
beside the subset and the worst part of
it all is you have to send the freaking
PDFs and sending the PDFs is four
minutes so you have one minute for this
to run okay so those are the practical
constraints so computational simplistic
is very very important here all right
and then once you compute the types what
would you do in a vanilla case you could
pick the arm with the highest index and
do this recursively
Etsy does it work here Spain has the
highest index I chose Spain
but I didn't learn anything so where
does the second test go to Spain again
and the third to Spain again that does
not make sense you are over exploring
and this is the idea that we used uh to
deal with this
so you have some belief about the
prevalence of a country
once I pull the arm from this country
I'm not gonna see the results
but do you guys have any intuition about
how the posterior distribution is going
to look like
let's see if it's positive it's going to
be shifted to the right
but it's going to be not over right
because you have one more sample if it's
negative it's going to be shifted to the
left it's also narrower so I can take an
essentially an expectation of how
distribution would look like
the mean should be a Martingale so have
the same mean but it should be narrower
cool
but since I know that the variance is
going to decrease can't I recalculate
the indices with this simulated
posterior
and essentially this is a way to
quantify the informational gains even if
you won't see the results until two days
later
so I allocate the test to Spain laying
the exponentially is going to drop why
because the variance is going to be
smaller and then I move on to the next
country and I do this over and over
again
and what is the extra benefit of this
that we're using exactly the same idea I
can simulate the information gained from
all the tests in the pipeline remember
two days ago I allocated 100 tests to
Germans I haven't seen the results using
this one I know in expectation how my
distribution is going to look like so I
can take into account what information
is about to arrive
oh yeah
and then the combinatorial constraints
where we use the heuristic approach
which I hope that your grid makes sense
so here was a problem there so you have
Spain Germany and Italy
you calculate the indices and
Germany is the highest but Germans may
show up either in the land border or the
airport
yeah
so where does it make sense to allocate
so you have a lot of capacity left
here at the land border and very little
capacity left at the airport
we did what we think makes sense we
allocated to the port of entry with the
most lift capacity in case somewhere in
the future some rare arrivals will show
up and we would like to explore with
Israel arrivals
make sense no theorence
just intuition there is no theorem in
the paper Okay so that's another view of
the algorithm what I would like to
discuss the results so
all right so let's see how we did it was
all this thing worth it
so the comparison that we're doing first
is against
what they were planning to do which was
random okay and uh what I'm going to
present is model Independence so it's a
inverse propensity the reason is that
you may hate my our learning model you
may hate an allocation algorithm so I
want to provide the result that does not
depend on any of that
all right so this is how we did the red
line versus what random would have done
so this is August September October
first of all in tuition does it make
sense that end of October the
performance Improvement is pretty small
if you were planning your dream vacation
in Greece would you ever go end of
October
right so the arrivals are very low and
therefore the value of targeting is very
small
so we focus for now on the peak season
and essentially there's the result is
that we increase the effectiveness of
testing by 85 percent more or less
double the testing capacity
at the time when testing was impossible
to scale right
okay and then what the critique here you
are comparing against the dumb benchmark
okay so now I'm starting touching upon
the questions that you guys asked will
and Kevin if I remember correctly
all right so why don't we use publicly
available data in order to do the same
so first problem with publicly available
data early 2020 is that they were
terrible
negative deaths missing data Etc so
let's say that we're creative about this
and we figure out a way that they are
well behaved
so this is how public policies based on
publicly available data perform versus
us so
we use proportional to cases per million
reported
that's permillion reported and
positivity of tests performed reported
and you still see that there is a
significant gap between what we do and
what a policy based on this data would
do
and let's start brainstorming why this
would be the case and we will invest
more time on this
any ideas yeah
second time I'm using this
so is it because there was a delay of
two weeks before like to show up like
things that send cases to show up
fantastic
so explanation number one is that
Community transmission does not
translate to cases until two weeks later
um back then there weren't enough tests
to go around so we weren't actually
getting valuable information or like
enough from those things so different
countries have different testing
capacities
right so really the information is very
censored that we get from publicly
reported data anything else
uh I don't know if this is true it's
more of a theoretical reason but maybe
like the distribution of people coming
to Greece is different than the
distribution of people going to other
countries based on Origin
fantastic point so the point is that did
any of you go to Greece again in 2020
no because like going to party in the
middle of a pandemic is Strike there is
a selection bias so these are all the
valid reasons here right
so let me actually show you in pictures
so these are two countries
Green Country blue country
the dust line is what we measure at the
border the prevalence estimate and the
solid line is the reported cases
if you didn't have access to the dust
line you would say oh blue blue look
looks legit the green one looks terrible
but they are equally bad at the border
wait I'm sorry what are these lines
again so those are cases per million for
two countries country green and Country
blue and the dust is the prevalence
estimate for Country green
uh variable assessment for Country blue
so from a public data point of view blue
looks better than Green
from a private data through prevalence
point of view at this point
they're equally scary right
so that's a reason why public data that
relates to what Rachel said that
probably what happened in this case is
that the blue one who was probably
either only reporting or testing
symptomatic people or did not have
enough tests
and then going to your point which was
very observant Community transmission
which is the red line that we observe
has a lag compared to the cases being
expressed in public reported numbers
unless you do an extreme amount of this
all right so now let's make this formal
what I'm going to do to answer your
question is the following I will try to
use publicly available data
to solve the following hypothesis
testing problem
so train models that users input
publicly available data and try to
predict whether this country has a
prevalence of more than five in a
thousand hence risky or less than 500
000 hence safe okay
so I'm going to start with the model
that Au recommended look at 14 day
average of cases per million and that's
per million
and then I will make it a little more
sophisticated 14 day averages of cases
death
per thousand and reported positivity
rate and try to see how well it predicts
risk
but then between us that's also unfair
because the drift should matter right
so why don't we use the whole time
series of cases and that's per million
or even the 14-day time series of cases
deaths
reported positivity and tests full so
that that's the most that you can do
pretty much
I will explain bundle five in a second
models one to four have an area under
the curve that's 0.5
so publicly reported data is not very
useful not predicting risk but there is
still some information signal right and
what is the information signal if you
now condition on what the country is if
you add country fixed effects then it
does have some information right the
0.622 model number five is everything
else including country fixed effects and
this it does have information
so the explanation kind of of this is
what rates and essentially was saying
that depending on your reporting and
testing protocols you should be using
different rules for different countries
now whether you can do it as a
politician no as you but it is what it
is
all right so
implications of these from a policy
perspective that we communic we gave a
talk at the European Council on this and
was not very well received is that if
you want to magnet to estimate the
magnitude of true prevalence there is no
one size fits-all rule at least when you
have very sparse data beginning of the
pandemic I don't know what the answer
would be today
uh so you have to use country specific
features but then it's Shady ethically
and politically
in any case the even the current
recommendations where they are using
these obscure models where there are
these like 500 thresholds on how many
tests they did and cases Etc there is no
model that is not country specific that
can predict risk accurately
okay
now that was a slide that I was talking
about in the beginning the lessons
learned the hard way
okay first of all this is something that
even inside the team
we had the
click interesting discussions about when
you work on these projects you have to
pick your fights as academics we're
always thinking about the optimization
problem
and then someone gives a practical
constraint and we're like no I don't
agree with the constraint they design
your whole organization at some point
this exchange has to stop right at some
points some fights are worth fighting
some are not
uh the second one which I I learned the
very hard way uh being in the meetings
with all the politicians is that we tend
to evaluate smartest smartness in terms
of technical ability there are other
kinds of smarts and we should recognize
that and we should not be very snobbish
about that some people may be even
smarter than us because they cannot
formulate their objective but their
objective makes sense and another one
that was very obvious in this work is
that if you have a goal I want to
achieve these change sometimes you have
to work on boring tasks like hamsa how
to present to people with no technical
backgrounds about exploration
exploitation trade-off we had to manage
the front-end engineers and like learn
how to like understand JavaScript and
how you make the system more robust
there are boring things that you have to
do to get to the end goal it's not all
going to be oh I'm talking to the Prime
Minister why don't you guys do that and
I'll check with you in a week you
actually have to do the boring stuff
now they on the end don't do it which
was the most painful part for me and for
us is that the most real projects and
I'm sure that right in her stories to
share and moon if she's here can be
heavily politicized so my advice is try
to stay away from publicity at the very
least until the paper is published
so you will be inclined and your Dean
will be calling you ahead you're working
on this project why don't you talk to
the news don't until you have results
that can be backed up with data don't
talk to anyone we are not trained to
deal with this and we don't think about
the implications because that's how our
brain works
in my opinion that that's something in
my personal opinion also once people
will realize how good we are and what
kind of skills we have they will start
asking us for random stuff to help with
other data science problems because they
can see the potential it's okay to say
no
only work on the stuff that you think
have an order one impact on whether this
project will happen or not the extreme
is that like there was a robbery at some
point and they were like okay if we give
you Anonymous data about XXX can you
narrow down the list of potential
suspects oh no I cannot right it's okay
to say no
uh also that's uh very close to heart is
that these projects come with very high
stress and uh 50 pounds later and like
two broken years later I I highly
recommend that you focus on your
emotional health it should be another
one priority during this project because
you can easily lose track of uh things
uh so yeah that's it and uh let's open
it up to questions
[Applause]
um why is this stuff shared with like
other countries like was there anything
specific about Greece such that like
maybe you couldn't could generalize
um yes so throughout the summer we were
talking to our counterparts to have a
data scientists and epidemiologists in
many European countries and without
obviously specifying which countries
this is a problem the
data infrastructure that's available to
countries is surprisingly terrible
to the extent that like
forgetting about reinforcement learning
at all keeping track of denominators
was not possible for example we had 10
positive tests from German today cool
out of how many
so like that was a big roadblock that
data maturity is very low there are many
explanations for this right it's
definitely not laziness
is that we are very conditioned on
working with s IR models which do not
rely that level of granularity or all
this privacy concerns make it
practically infeasible to implement
something until unless like a team a
large team of people work on this 24 7.
so the answer is yes we had these
passions with many but then the moment
we showed where we implemented it it was
like okay just let us know which hot
spots appear in the world please and uh
yeah
questions
I'm going to yeah
so I have one question about the data
you were showing about from September to
November is there any reason why the
number of infections was increasing but
the advantage of targeting was smaller
or were you showing cumulative yep data
okay thank you
so let me go to the slide that I skipped
so this is a good slide so advantage of
targeting if we do the following thought
experiment of plotting how much better
we are doing compared to random versus
the fraction of passengers tested
let's take it to an extreme like if the
fraction of tested was one
the advantage of targeting would be zero
or the ratio would be one right why
because like even if you target you're
testing everyone
so early on in the season somewhere
around here was the peak of arrivals so
uh between August and paper and
somewhere around here
so this is the distance between curves
the reason that this is increasing is
because the worldwide situation was was
becoming worse so the actual prevalence
was increasing over time and around this
time November November 10th it's where
most countries in Europe went on a
second lockdown
which is why we stopped the system and
this is why the number of infections is
large
but also catching more infections we are
cutting more infections yes
a lot more testing same testing but
people were more infected
uh just quick question about like the
rapid tests or in your other paper you
argued that maybe you don't want
actually a perfect test right so just
wondering if you ever floated that idea
because you had access to a decision
yeah so I definitely that was a mistake
that I made where I told you not to work
on things that are directly related to
the projects
I made that mistake and I worked on many
things that were not directly related to
the project one of them was I was trying
to make the case for Mass testing with
inaccurate tests sometime in like
July of 2020
and at the time we're like oh we don't
trust and that was exactly the point so
at some point I picked my fights and I
stopped this and then a year later they
implemented it so
I tried and I failed
what about pool testing uh was that one
of the design parameters yeah so pool
testing just to explain for everyone I
guess you already heard is that instead
of because you have limited capacity of
the equipment you are mixing all the
samples or subset of all the samples if
you find if it's negative the pulled
sample it's negative if you find
evidence you test them separately you
could do fancier than that divide and
conquer but that's how they did it so
yes they were doing pools of five that
was what was approved by the national
covet task force
I see but it wasn't one of the
parameters of your uh exactly because of
the way that they were doing it that
whenever it's positive they're testing
everyone you wouldn't have changed
everything now if they were doing
fancier pooling then it could have been
taken into account whether we would have
taken into account given the time
constraints the answer is probably no
but we could have yeah
I have kind of a two-part question uh
the first is could you talk a little bit
more about that process of like deciding
on objectives deciding on these
constraints like what did that look like
talking to people and then the second
part which is kind of related is you
have on your slide that like people are
smart in different ways and that like
they know they're objective but that was
the one example you gave so I was
wondering if you could elaborate on like
what are these like types of smartness
or like who are the kinds of people that
you want to be working with who are
doing something like this yeah
so that's a very good question I have to
think on the on the Fly
in terms of in terms of objective let's
start with the easy one what we could
have done differently is like explicitly
uh quantify the accuracy for risky ones
so that you can make even better gray
leasing decisions that's what I could
have changed
but then a then you have to you know
there is a parameter in the objective
who chooses this parameter someone was
talking about this in the panel I think
which is a very complicated
and the second one is that there is a
political aspect to this so when you go
and advertise we're having algorithm
that catches infections it better be the
objective that is I want to catch as
many infections as I can now regarding
the constraints they were literally
formed so the in the nightmare days of
this project in like May 2020 we
literally were sitting in a room or not
in a room in a zoom room with
the PM the Civil protection which was
defining essentially the operations of
the Port of Entry how many people he can
allocate it was a he at the time because
that was a minister they can allocate at
every point of entry which was Princess
number one and then was the public
health the Secretary General who was
saying look I can't move resources
around but if you change your mind it
will take me three weeks to move
resources around so you better get it
right the first time and the first time
was with no data right
uh so essentially these these
constraints
could be operationalized and written
down in math very easily in this
particular problem
now then you have Vishal in the room who
wanted to just change everything why
don't they buy a million QR Code Reader
so that border agents can do Dynamic
learning and then we dynamically render
arrivals sure you could do all of these
things but that's the point where you
say okay these constraints are easy to
formulate they're commonly acceptable we
found a way to do this you know let's
actually now start deploying
implementing and deploying yeah I hope I
answered your question
oh I got them
I really like what you said about how a
lot of times academics are not trained
to talk to journalists for these like
sensitive policy questions so I'm that's
a broad question but both are there
existing resources you feel like
um are useful for getting this kind of
training and if not what kinds of skills
or areas do you feel like academics
could improve on in order to communicate
with
uh public-facing organizations
uh was this was not on record that would
make my life easier but I will try to I
can also offline no I mean it's an
interesting question but like I made
this mistake once in the process of this
project and uh so before the paper was
published about six months before it was
published someone reached out from a
scientific looking like institution in
Greece about like what were the results
what's the status of the Publications
and I thought I was talking to
scientists so I made one public
statement and after that I had to like
help the government defend the project
in the parliament because like the
political opposition went bananas right
and then that was the one mistake that I
made in terms of like PR that I
regretted in terms of emotional health
like after that the paper was published
in nature and everything was solved so
in terms of resources I think you can be
sure you can do a lot of training
but I have a feeling that if you are
very good that
if you are very good at these political
games
I'm not sure if like your academic
skills are incredible because the way we
think about is like objective things
rational thinking
while being able to navigate this very
complex political situations I feel it's
exact opposite at least for someone with
my mental capacity uh so I feel that the
kind of contract contradict each other
and if you're in an organization that's
the best advice I got when I was doing
this project from the head
epidemiologist let the politicians do
the that work and you focus on the
science and that was the best the best
advice I got yeah
all right one one question I have about
uh the on the which covers you're using
so you said for Spain for example in
Barcelona had five and then you uh had
every everything else to be two for
example rather than focusing is there
something else we were updating every
day or is it something that you yeah let
me use it as an opportunity to also say
something else so the feature extraction
uh component was running every two weeks
and then the allocation was running
every day now in terms of features what
was available was as I said country
region City age and gender
AIDS and gender surprisingly were not a
predictive
and the region on the other hand was
very predictive initially we would like
we would have liked to add the
profession profession as a feature but
then that's where privacy comes in
the more features the number of people
you can identify with these features is
very small so that was a choice now if I
did this all over again I would have
taken profession over gender but it was
still the time where the world these
papers were saying women are okay with
coffee and epidemiologists you know
thought that this was a relevant metric
and there is a like there is a trade-off
time
thanks again